yeah I mean that's one thing people
don't think about like you know the
consumers of Van life content aren't
only like Wanderlust want to be
influencers that's such a good point bro
that's such a good point I mean it's
also dudes like that are like [__] like
this is sick like a bed that I could
move and what a crazy thought to have
watching a van life video where you
watch that and you go I could run away
from my family so funny it must be like
80 of the comments are like oh my God I
would love to explore the Redwood forest
in the Bay Area like like you uh I want
to leave Susan
20 percent of the comments are like so I
don't have to sleep in the same bed with
my wife anymore huh and and let's say if
I drove away my kids could never call as
well because they wouldn't they couldn't
find me as well yeah two